Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Bienvenue dans Septante Minutes Avec.
Dans le cadre de ce podcast, j'ai souvent eu l'occasion de discuter de problématiques de genre avec de formidables intervenants, comme quand on échangeait sur l'autisme avec Julie Dachez,
quand on a parlé de journalisme avec Martine Simonis et Myriam Leroy,
ou d'éducation avec Charlotte Bellier et Jérôme Colin.
Pour faire une bonne interview, moi, je trouve que c'est toujours intéressant de croiser les regards et en l'occurrence, ça a permis d'exposer un petit peu l'omniprésence des questions de genre au sein de toutes ces thématiques.
Mais après vingt-sept épisodes, il était grand temps d'aller encore plus loin et de dédier un épisode entier à ces questions.
Aujourd'hui, mon invitée nous parle du mythe de la virilité, de la prison qu'il représente pour les hommes et de l'oppression qui en résulte sur les femmes à travers le monde.
Et cerise sur le gâteau, on termine en croisant les disciplines et en parlant de la masculinité toxique en politique. C'est un épisode qui est plus long que d'habitude, mais il paraît que quand on aime, on ne compte pas.
Aujourd'hui, j'ai le plaisir de recevoir l'excellente Olivia Gazalé. C'est parti. Je suis aujourd'hui avec Olivia Gazalé.
Olivia Gazalé, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Olivia, tu es professeure de philo, notamment à Sciences Po Paris. Tu as publié ces dernières années deux livres. Le premier : Je t'aime à la philo, quand les philosophes parlent d'amour et de sexe, en 2012, publié chez Robert Laffont.
Et dernièrement, et c'est le livre dont nous allons parler aujourd'hui, tu es l'auteure d'un essai publié chez Robert Laffont également, nommé Le mythe de la virilité.
Merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté cette invitation.
Mais merci à toi.
Alors, on va, comme je l'ai dit, évoquer aujourd'hui les questions de genre-
Questions qui sont au cœur de nos sociétés, particulièrement, je pense, ces dernières années. Tu as fait le choix de prendre un angle, je ne sais pas si on peut dire inhabituel, mais
en tout cas un angle particulier pour aborder les questions de genre, c'est de te focaliser sur la question de la virilité.
Avant de rentrer au cœur du sujet, pour remettre un petit peu les choses en contexte, est-ce que tu peux nous expliquer d'où t'est venue cette flamme féministe, cette démarche féministe ?
Puisque ce que tu expliques dans le livre, c'est qu'on vit dans un système qui est renfermé sur lui-même et qu'il est difficile, voire même impensable, de remettre en question.
Pourtant, toi, avec ce livre, ce que tu fais, c'est que tu n'y vas pas avec le dos de la cuillère. C'est un livre qui est très pédagogique, très, très, très abordable, accessible.
Mais tu es en capacité de déconstruire ces codes alors que ce que tu expliques dans le livre, c'est que justement, c'est très difficile pour les personnes que nous sommes de remettre tout ça en question.
Alors, comment est-ce que tu fais ? D'où est-ce que ça te vient, cette démarche ?
Ça me vient, je pense, ça m'est venu du fait que je ne me reconnaissais absolument plus dans un certain nombre de discours relatifs aux rapports entre les hommes et les femmes.
Et que j'avais l'impression qu'il était temps de sortir de cette sorte d'impasse idéologique dans laquelle on est enfermé.
Enfin, on est vraiment prisonnier, comme d'ailleurs en témoignent les affrontements permanents sur les réseaux sociaux.
Et en fait, on n'est toujours pas sorti de la guerre des sexes. Et moi, c'était mon idée, c'était que oui, que côté femme, le féminisme a raison de dire que la femme est une victime de la domination masculine.
Le féminisme a raison de dénoncer les discriminations, les injustices, les violences dont souffrent toujours les femmes.
Parce que c'est une réalité, que le plafond de verre, que la violence, etc.
Mais il y a un piège dans lequel je crois qu'il faut se garder de tomber, c'est la misandrie ou l'androphobie,
c'est-à-dire de considérer que tous les hommes sont des prédateurs et qu'on ne peut pas analyser la question masculine sans sortir de cette question de l'homme oppresseur.
Et puis, de l'autre côté, côté homme, il y a un discours aussi dont je comprends l'origine, mais dont les effets m'agacent.
C'est le discours masculiniste, qui fait de plus en plus d'émules aux États-Unis notamment, et aussi en Europe,
et qui consiste à dire que c'est maintenant la fin des hommes, que les femmes, avec l'émancipation féminine, les ont en quelque sorte émasculés, évincés.
Il y en a même qui parlent de tyrannie féminine, et qui consiste à considérer que maintenant, l'oppresseur, c'est la femme.
Et donc, je trouvais que ces deux discours, qui étaient complètement irréconciliables, ne menaient nulle part et qu'ils ne pouvaient-- surtout qu'ils étaient--
on ne peut pas les faire dialoguer, ce sont vraiment deux discours radicaux.
Donc, je me suis dit : Comment est-ce qu'on peut essayer de sortir de cette impasse idéologique ? Et à mon sens, enfin, l'idée maîtresse de mon livre, d'ailleurs, c'est le sous-titre,
c'est que le sexisme enferme les deux sexes, est un piège pour les deux sexes.
Donc, en fait, essayer d'en sortir ou de déconstruire sera une émancipation non seulement pour les femmes, mais aussi pour les hommes qui sont aussi les victimes de ce système.
C'est très bien résumé. C'est un magnifique pitch, mais donc on va, pour ce faire, on va commencer par remon-- enfin dans ton livre, tu commences par remonter jusqu'à la nuit des temps, jusqu'au Néolithique.
Même au Paléolithique.
Même au Paléolithique, oui, bien avant l'invention de l'écriture, pour tenter de trouver les sources, les racines, les origines de, voilà, ces constructions que sont les genres.
On va devoir, je pense, avant de se lancer au cœur du sujet, prendre le temps de définir un petit peu tous ces termes.
Quand on dit, quand on emploie le mot homme, on peut parler, et c'est souvent source de confusion, on peut souvent parler de sexe, le sexe masculin.
Ça peut aussi signifier le genre masculin. Et puis tu rajoutes dans ton livre un troisième concept qui est le concept de la virilité.
Ok.
Alors, est-ce que tu peux, pour nos auditeurs et nos auditrices, définir un petit peu les différences entre ces trois concepts ?
Oui, alors d'abord, attirer l'attention de l'auditeur et auditrice sur le fait que le mot homme, c'est une métonymie quand même assez révélatrice parce que c'est à la fois l'ensemble du genre humain, au sens de humanité
et le genre masculin qui n'en constitue que la moitié.
Donc ça voudrait dire qu'en fait, le masculin est assimilé à l'universel.
L'humain par défaut est un homme, ouais.
Voilà. Voilà. Donc ça, c'est déjà un premier piège dans la langue française en tout cas. Et puis maintenant, je pense que ce qui est très important, c'est de distinguer masculinité et virilité.
Et masculinité, pour moi, je les pense au pluriel. C'est-à-dire que je préfère dire les masculinités comme je préfère dire les féminités.
Ce sont toutes les façons qu'il y a d'habiter le sexe masculin. De la même manière qu'il y a des féminités, qu'on a voulu normaliser en disant voilà la femme avec un grand F, l'éternel féminin, c'est ceci ou cela.
On a essentialisé la femme. Et la virilité, c'est le pendant de ça, c'est-à-dire c'est le modèle normatif, l'idéal normatif qu'on a désigné aux hommes comme le seul modèle possible ou en tout cas le meilleur modèle possible,
sous peine de ne pas être considéré comme un vrai homme.
Donc la virilité, c'est un idéal qui est très
normé, très coercitif et dont on va, je pense qu'on va le, je vais le montrer avec toi en déroulant un peu, mais j'ai voulu montrer que c'était un idéal qui était en plus très discriminatoire et en plus bourré de paradoxes.
Donc voilà, la différence, c'est que d'un côté,
on a les hommes dans leur immense diversité et la virilité, elle, qui est un modèle qui tend à vouloir uniformiser la diversité en réalité et qui lui fait du mal puisque ça consiste à exclure en fait de l'humanité tous les hommes.
Enfin, pardon, exclure, pardon, de la masculinité tous les hommes qui ne sont pas porteurs des canons virils.
Mmm mmm. Et donc tu expliques que ces canons de la virilité, donc déjà ce que tu expliques, c'est que le mot virilité vient du latin vir et que donc c'est, voilà, c'est vraiment cet idéal de masculinité
fort, combatif, qui est maître de ses émotions, qui ne se laisse pas, enfin, qui est toujours,
qui garde toujours le contrôle sur son environnement et sur lui-même.
Cet idéal, est-ce qu'il est entièrement construit ? Est-ce qu'il est entièrement, entre gros guillemets, artificiel ou bien est-ce qu'il va tirer justement ses racines dans l'inné, dans le naturel ?
C'est toujours la question de l'inné et l'acquis quand on parle des questions de genre. Toi, en remontant jusqu'à la nuit des temps, jusqu'au Paléolithique,
j'ai le sentiment que c'est un petit peu ce que tu as essayé de faire, c'est de montrer les sources de ces construits dans la nature.
Alors, je dirais pas tout à fait ça comme ça. Et là, c'est, tu soulèves tellement de choses que je sais pas par où prendre et comment te répondre.
Mais une chose à la fois, ça ira.
Oui alors,
déjà, la problématique de la nature et de la culture, elle est extrêmement complexe, évidemment, et je ne suis pas de celles qui pensent que la nature n'existe pas et que tout est cent pour cent construit.
Je pense qu'il y a effectivement, moi, je ne nie pas qu'il y ait des hommes et des femmes, même si évidemment, il y a aussi des gens qui sont entre les deux et que cette binarité mérite aussi d'être discutée.
Mais ce qui est en tout cas troublant, c'est que la nature a très inégalement distribué les attributs de force, de puissance, de taille à l'intérieur même du genre masculin.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a des hommes qui ne sont ni puissants, ni forts, ni musclés, qui sont petits, étriqués, etc. Ils n'en demeurent pas moins des hommes.
Sauf que toute l'histoire de l'humanité leur a fait comprendre qu'ils étaient des sous-hommes ou des moitiés d'hommes ou des demi-hommes.
Et en réalité, la construction intervient à partir du moment où on érige un modèle en oubliant que, en faisant passer tout ce modèle pour entièrement naturel alors qu'il demande une construction.
C'est-à-dire, de la même manière que Simone de Beauvoir a écrit : On ne naît pas femme, on le devient. Et on peut dire : On ne naît pas homme, on le devient.
C'est-à-dire que devenir un homme, c'est un processus qui est assez douloureux et qui s'est exercé au cours de l'histoire à travers de la violence même.
Parce que démontrer sans arrêt son appétit de puissance, son aptitude à dominer, des facultés d'autocontrôle, de rétention émotionnelle, se montrer fort, courageux, ardent au combat, victorieux, voire héroïque.
Parce que tu parlais de la racine latine de vir, mais ça remonte encore plus loin au sanskrit qui veut dire héros.
Ne jamais montrer ses failles, ne jamais pleurer, mépriser la souffrance, défier la mort. Tout ça, ça n'est pas naturel.
C'est quelque chose qui demande une éducation, un dressage, et qui s'acquiert avec le temps.
Maintenant, l'autre dimension de la question que tu me posais qui est que je remonte au Paléolithique. Alors première chose, en fait, ce que j'ai voulu essayer de comprendre, c'est quelle était l'origine de la domination masculine.
Est-ce qu'il y avait eu une phase de l'humanité où le monde ne s'était pas encore en quelque sorte virilisé, où cette domination masculine n'était pas devenue hégémonique ?
Et alors là, il faut être extrêmement prudent parce qu'on connaît très mal le Paléolithique. Et pour cause, il n'y a pas de traces écrites.
Et pour cause, il n'y avait pas d'écriture. Donc, on ne sait pas très bien, mais ce qu'on sait, c'est qu'il y a une grande déesse mère des origines qui a été adorée pendant des dizaines de millénaires avec des prophétesses femmes.
Et on sait aussi qu'il y avait beaucoup de sociétés dans lesquelles les droits, les prérogatives de chacun, de chaque sexe étaient beaucoup plus équilibrés, beaucoup mieux partagés.
Et ces sociétés ont laissé des traces dans l'histoire comme des espèces de fossiles archéologiques. On les voit par exemple chez les Iroquois,
qui est une société où, sans parler de gynécocratie, hein, on va dire que les femmes bénéficient d'une autorité sociale et morale, des sociétés qui sont matrilinéaires, c'est-à-dire que la transmission du patrimoine,
et des biens se fait par la mère.
Les femmes pouvaient nommer et révoquer les chefs, etc. Donc
en fait, le simple fait qu'il existe des sociétés dans lesquelles le patriarcat, enfin des sociétés non patriarcales, en réalité, ça remet tout en cause parce que ça veut dire que c'est pas si naturel que ça.
Il suffirait d'une seule société d'ailleurs pour faire mentir la thèse naturaliste, c'est-à-dire l'idée que ça a toujours été comme ça et que de toute façon l'homme domine parce qu'il est plus fort.
Ben voilà, c'est comme ça. Non, il y a des sociétés dans lesquelles ça ne s'est pas fait comme ça. Et donc ces sociétés nous invitent à réfléchir sur ce qu'on croit universel.
Oui, tu évoques la thèse
naturaliste. Un argument qui revient souvent à ce niveau-là, c'est la question de, voilà, la musculature supérieure de l'homme, qui a permis historiquement aux hommes de soumettre les femmes à leur volonté.
Hein, on pense aux féminicides, on pense aux viols et à toutes ces choses-là. Et ce que tu expliques, c'est que finalement, ça n'est pas si essentiel que ça dans la question.
Alors déjà, cette histoire de la force physique, elle est en débat. Elle nourrit un débat,
parce qu'on se demande si cette infériorité physique est la cause de l'infériorité de la femme ou la conséquence.
Et il y a certains chercheurs qui sont débattus, hein. Et moi, je ne prétends pas du tout dire la vérité là-dessus.
Je ne suis pas scientifique, mais il y a une anthropologue sociologue qui s'appelle Priscille Touraille, qui a mené une étude assez intéressante dans laquelle elle montre qu'en réalité, le fait que les femmes
aient toujours eu-- enfin, il y a une différence nutritionnelle entre les garçons et les fillettes un peu partout à travers le monde.
Et donc les hommes, on leur réserve les protéines, les parties nobles de la viande. Et puis les femmes, on leur donne les bouillies, les restes qui sont très pauvres en nutriments.
Et donc cette sociologue explique, anthropologue explique que
peut-être cette différence de musculature ne serait pas uniquement génétique ou naturelle, mais qu'elle pourrait aussi résulter de l'infériorisation de la femme, donc être une conséquence.
Donc je sais que c'est très débattu. Il y a eu aussi un très beau documentaire de Véronique Kleiner qui montre aussi ça.
Et d'ailleurs, on voit très bien que dans beaucoup de pays encore, vous allez en Inde ou énormément de pays, les filles et les garçons ne sont pas nourris de la même manière.
Donc ça pourrait être une piste. Donc ça, mais là, encore une fois, je suis prudente parce que je n'ai pas de certitude sur cette idée que vraiment le-
Oui.
Bon, je ne sais pas.
Oui, mais ce que tu expliques, c'est que dans tous les cas-
Dans tous les cas.
Même s'il y avait ce facteur de la musculature, ça ne suffirait pas.
Voilà. Quand bien même les hommes seraient naturellement plus forts, plus grands par nature, ce qui est possible, je ne sais pas,
ça ne suffirait pas parce que c'est Rousseau qui a très bien dit : "Le plus fort n'est jamais assez fort pour être toujours le maître s'il ne transforme l'obéissance en devoir."
C'est-à-dire que l'homme n'aurait pas pu imposer une domination aussi aliénante pour la femme pendant des millénaires, en s'appuyant uniquement sur la force.
Parce qu'avec cette logique-là, excuse-moi, je vais dire quelque chose qui est peut-être pas très élégant pour l'ancien président de la République française, mais avec cette idée-là, un homme,
plus petit que sa femme d'ailleurs, qui fait moins d'un mètre soixante-dix ne peut pas-- un mètre septante, pardon, septante, comme le titre de l'émission.
Un homme d'un mètre septante n'aurait jamais pu être président de la République. Ce n'est pas la force qui fait le pouvoir et la puissance, c'est l'importance idéologique qu'on donne à la force.
Et c'est pas du tout la même chose. Donc ça, en revanche, c'est construit. Et donc on a toujours voulu persuader les femmes qu'elles n'avaient pas de puissance physique, de les éloigner de la guerre, etc.
Mais c'était pour des raisons idéologiques. C'était pour les garder à la maison, c'était pour les garder enfermées, pour les assigner à la maternité, pour s'approprier leur fécondité, etc.
De la même manière qu'on a toujours persuadé les hommes qu'ils étaient par nature grands, musclés, puissants et valeureux.
Pourquoi ? Pour pouvoir les envoyer se tuer à la guerre. Et on leur a dit : "Vous n'avez pas d'émotions, vous n'avez pas peur,
vous n'êtes pas craintifs comme les femmes qui sont trouillards" pour pouvoir les envoyer se faire tuer sur le champ de bataille.
Et d'ailleurs, on disait même la belle mort. La seule belle mort pour un homme, c'est mourir sur le champ de bataille, l'arme à la main.
Et puis on n'avait aucun respect pour les survivants d'une guerre, parce que c'était ceux qui n'avaient pas été assez valeureux pour crever sur le champ de bataille.
Donc voilà, ça, c'est une utilité de ce modèle de virilité. J'aimerais juste revenir sur ce que tu évoquais il y a un instant, ces constructions, hein.
Donc tu parles dans ton livre d'un système théologico-politico-culturel. On va revenir là-dessus dans un instant.
Mais donc c'est toutes ces constructions pour persuader les hommes et particulièrement les femmes de leur impuissance, enfin de l'impuissance des femmes,
quelle est la motivation des hommes à ce moment-là pour mettre en place un tel système ?
Pourquoi est-ce que les hommes ont peur des femmes et pas l'inverse ?
Alors bon, là, tu soulèves une question immense, mais tout à l'heure, on disait que pendant des dizaines de millénaires, on avait adoré une divinité féminine.
Et il faut rappeler qu'à cette époque-là, on n'avait pas compris les mécanismes de la procréation, donc on n'avait pas compris le rôle fécondant ou inséminateur du sperme.
Donc on pensait que la femme avait des pouvoirs surnaturels, qu'elle accouchait toute seule. C'est le système de la parthénogenèse, comme Marie, comme-- donc l'idée-- Athéna aussi, qui accouche toute seule.
Et donc on voyait la femme comme avec des super pouvoirs. Donc ça, ça a véritablement de quoi effrayer. Et puis au cours du Néolithique, vraisemblablement, l'homme, en élevant les animaux au lieu de les chasser,
en comprenant les mécanismes de l'agriculture, comprend la fécondation et comprend le rôle de l'homme, évidemment.
Mais au lieu de considérer désormais qu'il y a deux pôles dans la procréation, ils vont vouloir tirer la couverture à eux, vraisemblablement par peur de cette surpuissance féminine, et aussi comprendre qu'à partir du moment où,
l'ovule, en fait, est une denrée rare par rapport à la multiplicité des spermatozoïdes.
Et donc la terreur, ça va être l'idée qu'on va donner son nom à un enfant qui n'est pas de son sang. Donc autrement dit, on va avoir peur que la femme porte l'enfant d'un autre.
Mmm-hmm.
Et donc il va falloir-
On va avoir peur de rompre la filiation, finalement.
Tout part de la filiation et c'est pour ça aussi que les sociétés deviennent à ce moment-là patrilinéaires.
C'est-à-dire, c'est le nom du père qui est donné, alors qu'autrefois, on donnait le nom de la mère puisqu'on ne connaissait qu'elle comme génitrice en réalité.
On n'avait pas du tout fait le rapprochement avec l'homme. C'est étonnant, mais c'est comme ça.
Ouais, c'est un rapprochement qui s'est fait, tu l'expliques, à partir du moment où les hommes et les femmes se sont sédentarisés.
C'est ça, au Néoli-
ont commencé à élever les animaux et donc ont tiré des conclusions sur la biologie.
Exactement ça, au Néolithique. Et du coup, ce qui l'importe maintenant, c'est de contrôler la gestation, de contrôler les ventres des femmes.
Donc ça va passer par une appropriation. D'ailleurs, les mécanismes du mariage, finalement, au départ, ne sont rien d'autre qu'un contrôle de la reproduction, et un échange de femmes pour contrôler la reproduction.
Donc en fait, c'est bien ça dont il s'agit. Et à partir de là, on a bâti tout un système idéologique pour faire croire aux femmes que c'était leur destin biologique et que tout ça était de l'ordre de la nature, alors qu'en réalité,
ça n'est pas la nature qui a fabriqué ça.
C'est une construction idéologique qui se fait passer pour la nature.
Et c'est pour ça que c'est très difficile aujourd'hui de le faire comprendre et de le déconstruire, parce que ce sont des représentations des deux sexes comme deux polarités totalement, vraiment opposées et hiérarchisées en plus,
qui se font face.
Et donc arriver à faire comprendre que ces polarités ne sont pas naturelles,
mais qu'elles ont été établies par des millénaires de représentations, de symboles et comme tu dis, enfin comme je l'ai dit mais exactement, théologico-politico-
même c'est pas beau comme expression.
Oh, j'aime beaucoup, moi.
Bah en fait, ça veut dire que cette construction idéologique a combiné tous les arguments d'autorité et toutes les disciplines.
C'est la mythologie, la religion, la science, la philosophie, le droit. J'en oublie. Oui, la biologie fait partie de la science, qui se sont en quelque sorte conjuguées ou liguées pour asseoir cette idée
de base, le postulat de base du virilisme, c'est la supériorité du sexe masculin ou même du principe masculin dans l'univers sur le principe féminin.
Ouais, alors y a effectivement de nombreux exemples sur lesquels on pourrait passer, hein. Le plus évident, ça va être les choses comme Adam et Ève ou Ève, voilà, sortie de la côte d'Adam, etc.
Avant de se lancer peut-être là-dedans, tu expliques dans ton livre que, voilà, la construction de ce système théologico-politico-culturel,
Ça plaît, ça.
Ah, j'aime beaucoup. Je vais le dire le plus de fois possible dans cet épisode. La motivation derrière la construction de ce système, il y a derrière ça trois peurs.
Et donc tu expliques la peur de la castration par la toute-puissance féminine, la hantise de l'effémination et la terreur de l'impuissance.
Et quand on dit impuissance, on parle ici de, voilà, de la panne sexuelle.
Mmm.
D'où elles viennent, ces peurs ?
Bah, ce sont des peurs archaïques, hein. Ce sont trois peurs archaïques, qui sont liées entre elles d'ailleurs. Cette image du féminin
tout-puissant a évidemment nourri dans la mythologie, et même dans la théologie, cette image d'une femme dangereuse, d'une femme même néfaste, maléfique, funeste, diabolique.
C'est l'image qu'on va retrouver après dans la sorcière. Donc on a, très tôt, hein, des images de femmes par qui tous les malheurs arrivent.
C'est Pandore, c'est Cassandre,
c'est Lilith, c'est Ève. À chaque fois, c'est une femme qui est coupable. Et donc cette idée de la femme coupable, elle est vraiment-- je m'arrête une seconde dessus, après, je reviens aux autres aspects, hein,
mais l'image de la femme coupable est vraiment fondamentale à comprendre parce que
c'est cette image de faute originelle de la femme qu'on trouve chez Lilith, chez Ève, chez Cassandre, chez Pandore, chez les sorcières.
Cette idée qu'en fait, dans la violence sexuelle, finalement, c'est la femme qui l'a cherché, c'est la femme qui est responsable.
On en a beaucoup entendu ça au moment de MeToo. Ah oui, mais elles ont qu'à pas nous provoquer, elles ont qu'à pas mettre des minijupes, etc.
Donc oui, c'est la femme, la tentatrice et le pauvre homme, lui, il n'a fait que succomber à des instincts.
Oui, c'est ça. Puisque l'idéal viril, c'est de maintenir le contrôle en permanence, mais la tentation, la libido que l'homme ne sait pas a priori contrôler, ça devient l'ennemi de la virilité, finalement.
Oui, et puis de toute façon, c'est la femme, la tentatrice, qui vient le détourner du droit chemin.
C'est la sirène, c'est Circé, c'est-- dans la mythologie. Très tôt, l'homme va incarner le logos, la raison, la rationalité, l'ordre, l'harmonie, etc.
Et la lumière, la clarté, le soleil. Et la femme, c'est l'ombre, le chaos, la passion, l'éros, tout ce qui est indomptable, tout ce qui est irrationnel, etc.
Et donc ce sont ces deux forces qui sont en lutte l'une contre l'autre, mais c'est vraiment le bien qui lutte contre le mal.
Et le mal, c'est M-A-L incarné par la femme. Donc l'homme incarne l'ordre, la lumière et la beauté et la femme, l'ombre, les ténèbres et le danger.
Donc ce sont vraiment ces deux... C'est cette terreur originelle de la femme, donc, qui explique aussi la peur de l'impuissance parce que
cette espèce de grotte infernale, il y a toutes sortes de mythologies originelles qui montrent que-- qui parlent du vagin denté, il y a des dents dans le vagin.
Il y a même des mythologies où ils disent qu'il y a une bête sauvage à l'intérieur qui peut accrocher, mordre le pénis, sinon il en sortira mutilé.
Enfin, toutes ces représentations diabolisantes de la femme qui ont laissé des traces dans l'inconscient collectif et qui font que encore maintenant, la femme peut paraître un danger et quelque chose qu'il faut dompter.
Et ça vient aussi de là, cette idée qu'il faut la contrôler et la surveiller et l'enfermer, derrière un voile, derrière tout ce qu'on veut.
Mais en tout cas, elle est un danger en soi.
Et est-ce que tu dirais que ces trois peurs qu'on évoquait il y a un instant, elles sont toujours actives aujourd'hui ? Mais je pose la question parce que,
voilà, si on résume la première peur à la peur de la castration par la toute-puissance féminine, je t'avoue que moi,
représentant, dans ce podcast, voilà, du genre masculin, je ne me réveille pas le matin en me disant : j'ai peur d'être castré aujourd'hui.
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose qu'on observe vraiment ? Comment est-ce que ça se manifeste dans la société ?
Alors, ce sont des peurs archaïques, c'est-à-dire ancestrales et qui sont gravées dans notre inconscient. C'est normal que tu te réveilles pas le matin en te disant : j'ai peur de me faire castrer.
Mais en réalité, il y a beaucoup, dans la sexualité masculine, il y a une inquiétude.
Depuis toujours, hein, si tu prends déjà chez les Grecs et chez les Romains, il y a d'abord une inquiétude quant aux mensurations.
Avec une angoisse de la comparaison par rapport aux autres. Et puis après, il y a cette angoisse de l'érection.
L'érection qui est justement, tout à l'heure, on disait,
on parlait du contrôle. En fait, il y a justement ce paradoxe dans la définition de la virilité entre la puissance et la maîtrise, parce que c'est pas du tout évident d'articuler les deux.
La puissance en matière sexuelle, c'est ce qui va encourager l'homme à faire la démonstration un peu ostentatoire de sa puissance sexuelle, comme la puissance sexuelle, finalement, est un peu l'indicateur du pouvoir tout court.
Donc, plus on a de conquêtes sexuelles, plus on est conquérant. Regarde les discours de Trump sur le nombre de ses...
voilà, c'est... Donc l'un est l'indice de l'autre. Donc, en gros, j'ai un gros phallus, donc je suis très puissant et j'ai plein de maîtresses et j'ai plein de conquêtes, tout ça, ça va ensemble.
Mais la maîtrise, c'est un peu l'antidote de ça. C'est je peux me maîtriser, je peux me contrôler. Et donc même, j'irais même jusqu'à dire que
il y a eu un contre-modèle très important au chevalier médiéval fougueux et qui violait volontiers les femmes dans les villages conquis.
C'était le modèle, le contre-modèle du moine qui, lui, au contraire, n'avait pas de vie sexuelle et qui était pour le salut de l'humanité.
Donc en fait, on s'est demandé pendant tout le Moyen Âge et même au-delà, qui était le plus viril du moine ou du soldat, c'est-à-dire celui qui fait la démonstration de sa puissance par l'arme et par les conquêtes sexuelles, ou
au contraire, celui qui était capable de sublimer les instincts, de les esthétiser, de ne pas leur donner libre cours, en se domestiquant, en se gouvernant.
Et alors, pour en revenir à cette peur de l'impuissance masculine,
tu n'as peut-être pas, quand tu te réveilles, peur de te faire castrer,
mais il y a beaucoup d'hommes, et je parle-- on voudrait bien te parler de toi précisément,
mais enfin, les hommes ont peur du fiasco, ce qu'on appelait le fiasco autrefois, la peur de la panne érectile, si tu veux.
Et ça, c'est quand même ça l'idée de l'impuissance. C'est l'idée que
comment on va satisfaire l'ogresse si elle a des besoins sexuels insatiables, puisque c'est comme ça qu'elle est représentée en tant que sorcière dans l'imaginaire
inconscient, peut-être pas de toi, homme d'aujourd'hui, moderne, du XXIᵉ siècle, de moins de trente ans,
mais enfin, elle a marqué les esprits, pendant des siècles, cette idée d'une femme ogresse sorcière et d'un homme qui devait absolument la satisfaire, mais ça allait être compliqué.
Et j'attire simplement ton attention sur le fait que cette obsession de la puissance sexuelle, elle est intéressante à analyser parce que si tu veux, aucun organe ne fonctionne de manière parfaite.
C'est-à-dire que si les hommes s'étaient contentés d'avoir un pénis, c'est-à-dire un organe de la reproduction,
ils se seraient peut-être très bien accommodés des petites pannes érectiles, parce que ça aurait été peut-être pas plus grave qu'une indigestion ou un rhume.
Mais ils ont fait du pénis un phalos, comme disent les Grecs, un phallus, c'est-à-dire un symbole de pouvoir et de domination.
Et tout part de là. Donc, si tu fais de ton phallus un symbole de domination, ce qui n'a pas l'air d'être le cas,
en ce qui te concerne, eh bien là, tu as peur de l'impuissance, de la panne érectile parce qu'elle signale que tu n'es pas un vrai homme, tu déchois dans la virilité.
Et j'irais même plus loin. La théologie a constitué l'impuissance comme une faute spirituelle depuis Saint Augustin.
D'accord, OK, je ne savais pas.
Il nous dit qu'Adam, au paradis, tout allait très bien pour lui. Il n'avait pas de problème à domestiquer son phallus.
À partir du moment où on a chuté à cause de la femme, je te le rappelle, à cause d'Ève qui a croqué la pomme, la vilaine.
Eh bien à partir de ce moment-là, l'homme aussi a chuté et Augustin nous dit : Bah voilà, Adam a désobéi à Dieu. Eh bien, pour le punir, son sexe ne lui obéira plus.
C'est ça la punition. C'est une punition divine.
Oui, et donc là ici, on examine des exemples de rapports entre le masculin et le féminin, le rapport entre les deux genres, enfin les deux sexes.
Est-ce que ce système que tu appelles donc système virilarchal et pas patriarcal, est-ce que c'est seulement une question de rapport masculin ou féminin ou bien est-ce que ça dépasse cette dichotomie ?
Ah oui, alors c'est tout. C'est tout l'objet de mon livre. C'est de montrer que si tu veux, ce que cette construction hiérarchisée des sexes a produit en termes d'oppression de la femme, de relégation domestique, etc.
sont des choses bien connues hein, voilà, et qui sont débattues par le féminisme depuis déjà maintenant plus de deux siècles. En revanche,
le fait que ce système opprime également les hommes,
ça, c'est en revanche un impensé. Enfin, ça commence maintenant à émerger dans le débat public, cette question de la masculinité qui pourrait être aussi un piège pour l'homme, c'est-à-dire aussi une forme d'enfermement pour l'homme.
Ça, c'est beaucoup plus tabou. C'est-à-dire, c'est toute la démonstration de mon livre, dont le sous-titre est Un piège pour les deux sexes.
C'est de montrer qu'il y a aussi une oppression de l'homme par l'homme.
Puisque de fait, tous les hommes qui ne possèdent pas les marqueurs de la virilité triomphale, héroïque, performante, combative et j'en passe, ont toujours été stigmatisés, voire ostracisés, voire tués.
Donc, en ce sens, c'est un mythe qui est, enfin une construction qui est aussi très mortifère pour l'homme lui-même.
Là, on revient sur le prisme, le facteur du genre ou le facteur du sexe. En posant cette question, j'avais en tête éventuellement de voir si ça pouvait avoir des conséquences sur d'autres attributs.
Je pense par exemple à l'orientation sexuelle, par exemple, à la question du handicap, ce genre de choses-là. Est-ce que tu fais un lien entre ce système virilarchal et ces autres discriminations ?
Mais précisément, mais bien sûr, bien sûr. Parce que justement, les hommes qui ne sont pas considérés comme de vrais hommes, évidemment, entre guillemets, qui n'arborent pas les attributs de la virilité,
ce sont au premier chef ceux qu'on a appelés les efféminés ou les invertis, les pédés.
Il y a toutes sortes de noms toujours très discriminatoires et très péjoratifs pour qualifier ce qui est considéré comme une déviance et non pas simplement comme une forme de la sexualité comme une autre
et qui ont donc toujours été condamnés et rejetés hors de la communauté des hommes.
Et simplement, je voudrais rappeler ici que les deux sont liés, c'est-à-dire l'homophobie découle directement de la gynéphobie.
C'est-à-dire que c'est parce que le féminin est dégradé que l'effémination est considérée comme dégradante. Donc c'est complètement lié.
Les deux sont liés. C'est pour ça que les luttes LGBT sont liées au combat féministe d'après moi. Et d'autre part, avec des généralisations qui sont,
enfin, complètement abusives à mon sens, parce qu'on va assimiler effémination et homosexualité.
Alors qu'on connaît des hommes qui sont très virils selon les canons définis et qui sont homosexuels et d'autres qui sont homosexuels sans être efféminés.
Donc en fait, là encore une fois, c'est parce qu'on a défini un idéal très normatif et qu'il faut absolument rentrer dans une case.
Donc si on est efféminé, on est forcément homo et puis si on est très viril, on est forcément hétéro. Mais c'est complètement absurde.
C'est trop schématique, oui.
Tu me disais, est-ce que en termes d'effémi-- alors les efféminés ont toujours été rejetés, les homosexuels, les handicapés aussi bien entendu, parce qu'à partir du moment où tu es un homme, mais que tu n'es pas
fort et triomphal et que en plus tu te fais réformer au service militaire, bah voilà, tu sers à rien.
Voilà, t'es pas un vrai homme, tu peux pas te battre, tu sais pas te battre, t'es pas un homme. Donc bien sûr, les handicapés ont souffert, mais plus généralement, sans aller jusqu'au handicap,
les hommes de petite taille ou de petit gabarit ont toujours aussi et souffrent encore aujourd'hui de harcèlement à l'école quand ils sont petits, de discrimination à l'embauche parfois.
La norme virile, elle exerce des effets mortifères à beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup de niveaux.
Tu expliques aussi qu'il y a cette notion de passivité observée chez la femme en ce qui concerne son cycle menstruel.
Ah alors là, alors là, on touche une affaire extrêmement sensible, c'est la question du rapport au sang. C'est-à-dire, tout à l'heure, on disait que c'était un système théologico-politico-culturel, etc.
Tu n'arrives plus à le dire.
Non. Parce que quand j'ai dit ça, je crois que j'ai écrit, je me souviens plus très bien parce que c'était il y a deux ans que j'ai écrit ce bouquin, mais de mémoire, j'ai dit : C'est un terme très laid.
Oui, tu le dis dans le livre, oui.
Voilà, je le dis. On dirait, si cette expression n'était pas aussi laide, on dirait c'est un système théologico-politico-culturel
Et dans ce système, il y a évidemment la science qui a joué un rôle majeur dans la construction des sexes.
Or, la médecine antique et médiévale était absolument persuadée que la grosse différence de nature entre les hommes et les femmes venait du rapport que chacun des deux genres entretient avec le sang.
Ça nous vient d'Aristote aussi, qui en fait considère que la femme perd son sang. Elle a un rapport au sang qui est passif, elle perd son sang dans ses règles, dans ses menstruations.
Et dans cette perte de sang, elle est complètement passive, c'est-à-dire qu'elle assiste à ses menstruations. Elle n'a aucun rôle actif là-dessus.
Elle ne sait jamais à quel âge, à quel moment, quelle semaine, etc. La grossesse aussi est toujours un mystère pour elle, le retour de couches, etc.
Donc on n'a aucun contrôle là-dessus. Et les médecins antiques et médiévaux, à partir des recherches d'Aristote, en ont déduit que la femme
ne peut se gouverner, donc elle est incapable de gouverner quoi que ce soit.
Elle ne se maîtrise pas, donc elle est incapable de maîtriser quoi que ce soit. Elle ne se contrôle pas, donc elle ne peut contrôler quoi que ce soit.
En revanche, lui, l'homme, est défini par la maîtrise. Et son rapport au sang est totalement différent puisque c'est un rapport actif au sang.
Il verse son sang à la guerre ou il le donne par la belle mort, la fameuse. Donc lui, il a un rapport au sang qui est glorieux, alors que la femme a un rapport au sang qui est impur.
Donc tout ça fait, comment dire, c'est à partir de cette différence biologique qu'on a décrété une inégalité sociale et politique.
Donc c'est ça le piège. Moi, je ne nie pas qu'il y ait cette différence. Je ne nie pas que les femmes ont leurs règles et les hommes pas.
Ça, c'est une différence naturelle quasi indépassable, sauf anomalie hein, mais elle est quasi indépassable. Le problème n'est pas là.
Le problème, c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait de cette différence ? C'est à partir du moment où une différence biologique est transformée en une inégalité sociale et en une hiérarchisation des sexes que là, ça devient dangereux.
Et ce qu'on a fait de cette histoire de règles, eh bien ça a fini par exclure les femmes de toutes sortes de fonctions, notamment la guerre, parce qu'une femme qui perd son sang a été réputée ne pas pouvoir verser le sang.
Une femme qui perd son sang ne peut pas chevaucher aussi, donc ne peut pas monter à cheval, donc ne peut pas faire la guerre.
Et c'est toutes ces choses qu'on a définies à partir d'une différence naturelle pour en faire une inégalité politique.
Donc, il y avait derrière cette idée d'exclure les femmes de ces fonctions hein, tu l'as dit, la guerre, la boucherie, le fait d'être marin, etc.
Ouais.
Il y avait derrière cette idée, et ça, c'est un concept que j'aimerais bien que, sur lequel j'aimerais bien que tu nous éclaires un petit peu, cette idée qu'il faut séparer le même du même.
C'est-à-dire qu'à partir du moment où on est un être qui saigne, on ne peut pas se prêter à une fonction
liée au saignement et ça va avoir des conséquences, même jusque dans l'Église catholique où, voilà, il y a ce principe de transformation du vin en sang.
Et donc, par conséquent, les femmes ne peuvent pas devenir prêtres. Est-ce que tu peux nous éclairer sur ce concept ?
Alors ça, c'est une hypothèse que formule Alain Testart dans un livre qui s'appelle L'Amazone et la cuisinière. Donc, je lui emprunte vraiment cette analyse, elle n'est pas de moi,
et qui montre justement, enfin, son hypothèse, c'est que si toutes les femmes ont été éloignées de toutes ces professions, c'est parce que justement, comme elles saignaient,
elles ne pouvaient pas en même temps saigner et verser le sang.
Et du coup, c'est comme ça qu'il explique qu'elles ont été éloignées de toutes les professions que tu as évoquées, notamment la boucherie.
Et d'ailleurs, juste une petite parenthèse hein, je reviens tout de suite au sujet, mais la boucherie, c'est intéressant parce que
tu as souvent, même dans les foyers, cette chose qui a été intériorisée, que la femme, même si c'est elle qui a fait cuire le rôti, elle va appeler son mari au moment de le découper.
Parce que c'est le fait de trancher, de verser le sang, est quelque chose qui est perçu comme assez masculin. Je referme la parenthèse.
Donc, tu disais, ça a des incidences théologiques et-
Oui, mais surtout cette idée de base comme quoi il faut séparer le même du même.
Oui.
On ne mélange pas deux choses qui se ressemblent. Et c'est ce qui mène aussi indirectement à la question de l'—
À l'homophobie.
Oui.
Parce qu'on ne mélange pas le sperme avec le sperme.
Mais quel étrange concept. Enfin, pourquoi est-ce qu'on ne mélange pas le...
Alors, parce qu'en fait, le monde a été pensé sur un mode binaire depuis les origines de la civilisation.
D'accord, donc une dichotomie perpétuelle entre tout.
Il faut qu'il y ait deux polarités.
C'est ça.
Et si tu regardes plus attentivement, cette polarisation masculin-féminin recouvre, elle va bien au-delà des deux genres, des deux sexes.
C'est-à-dire, c'est le cosmos entier qui est considéré comme binaire, ou en tout cas fonctionnant sur des binarités hiérarchisées.
Donc c'est par exemple le chaud, le froid,
le chaud étant masculin et étant considéré comme supérieur au froid. De même pour le sec et l'humide, de même pour le haut et le bas, mais aussi pour l'extérieur qui est la sphère masculine et l'intérieur qui est la sphère féminine.
Et à chaque fois, ce sont des sphères hiérarchisées. Donc en fait, on a besoin, la société, la civilisation occidentale a eu besoin de fonctionner sur ce mode binaire.
Pas un, pas trois, deux. Deux comme les deux sexes. Et c'est pour ça aussi que cette civilisation a autant de mal à accepter les transgenres parce que justement, ils démentent avec toute la force de l'évidence
l'universalité du binarisme.
Et là où c'est une construction, c'est que le chaud et le froid, ça n'existe pas en soi. Tu vas te dire qu'il fait chaud quand il fait trente degrés, mais trente degrés, c'est très froid par rapport à quatre mille degrés. Donc—
Ce sont des notions relatives, ouais.
Ce sont des notions complètement relatives. Le froid, le chaud, c'est... il n'y a pas de chaud dans l'absolu ou de froid.
De la même manière—
Il y a le zéro absolu en température.
Voilà. Voilà. Alors, il y a la femme absolue. Donc les polarités intangibles n'existent pas en réalité dans la nature.
Elles sont des constructions. Donc,
ça rejoint la question que tu me posais : on ne peut pas mélanger le même avec le même parce que c'est tout l'ordre symbolique, les fondations mêmes de notre système de pensée et de notre vision du cosmos qui seraient ébranlées.
Et ça, c'est ce que la pensée occidentale ne veut surtout pas, parce que nous sommes rationalistes, nous sommes les héritiers de Descartes, d'Aristote.
Donc, il nous faut de la clarté.
Oui, tu dis système occidental. Est-ce que... on évoquait tout à l'heure le souhait de trouver ailleurs dans le monde une civilisation qui différerait à ce niveau-là.
Est-ce que tu connais à ce moment-là une civilisation où ce n'est pas le cas du tout et où ces problèmes-là ne se présentent pas ?
Une civilisation, je ne sais pas, mais en tout cas une pensée, par exemple, le système de pensée bouddhiste, l'idée que
le yin est dans le yang et le yang dans le yin, c'est une pensée qui me paraît beaucoup plus féconde.
C'est-à-dire l'idée qu'il n'y a pas des polarités essentielles et radicalement opposées, mais que l'un est dans l'autre, et réciproquement.
Donc, nous avons tous... toute femme comporte une part de masculin et tout homme une part de féminin. Et c'est pour ça que, d'après moi, un homme qui repasse ou qui pouponne ou qui fait des tâches ménagères ne se féminise pas.
Pour en revenir à cette notion, donc c'est très enrichissant ce que tu viens d'expliquer sur la notion de polarité.
Pour en revenir à la notion de, voilà, du cycle menstruel. Donc, tu l'expliquais, c'était perçu comme étant presque, voilà, une pourriture, une saleté, quelque chose d'absolument impur.
Mmh, mmh.
Est-ce qu'aujourd'hui, pour avancer, mine de rien, de deux mille ans dans la chronologie, est-ce qu'aujourd'hui, on observe des femmes qui assument ça complètement ?
Parce que j'ai l'impression que c'est encore très tabou aujourd'hui hein, et qu'à la limite, on peut faire des blagues à Hollywood sur pipi caca, etc.
Et rigoler comme des enfants. Mais en revanche, parler du cycle menstruel de manière tout à fait libérée, comme si c'était un sujet tout à fait anodin, je crois que ça n'est pas encore le cas.
Où est-ce qu'on en est à ce stade ?
Bon, là, il y a
des tenantes aujourd'hui d'un activisme menstruel hein, qui est en plein essor. C'est une nouvelle génération de féministes qui veut justement briser le tabou
et puis qui même invite à célébrer le sang, qui vient de leur, ce qu'elles appellent leur lune intérieure, même aussi parfois à le recueillir dans des coupes.
On peut même l'utiliser comme engrais. On peut arborer de la lingerie et des bijoux rouges quand on a ses règles. Il y en a même qui ont élevé le tampon hygiénique au rang d'œuvre d'art.
D'accord, ouais. Ça relève plus de la gimmick, là, à ce moment-là.
Oui, ben, non—
Plus anecdotique.
...parce que ça veut dire... je comprends l'idée. C'est l'idée que ça suffit de considérer que le sang est impur.
S'il n'y avait pas les règles, il n'y aurait pas la fécondation et s'il n'y avait pas la fécondation, il n'y aurait pas de génération à venir. Donc
voilà, notre sang n'est pas sale. Alors simplement,
il a été considéré comme sale. Ça, ce sont les religions qui ont posé cette impureté du sang parce que
comme il tombait à terre, il se mêlait à la vie grouillante de la terre, il était réputé nourrir les insectes et la vermine.
Donc c'est tout ça qui a construit son impureté. Et il est temps effectivement qu'on sorte de cette vision.
Mais tu sais, il y a encore pas mal de pays dans le monde où la femme doit se cacher, vivre à l'écart pendant qu'elle a ses règles.
Chez les orthodoxes,
chez les Juifs orthodoxes, elle doit encore même
faire chambre à part pendant toute la durée de ses règles et ensuite, montrer vraiment qu'elle n'a plus une seule petite goutte de sang avant de pouvoir redormir avec son mari, reprendre une vie, une activité sexuelle, etc.
Donc, on est encore... Le tabou est encore très très présent.
Oui. Et, à titre personnel, toi-même, est-ce que tu estimes que tu t'es émancipée, tu t'es libérée de ce tabou ou bien est-ce que c'est encore quelque chose que tu ressens ?
Alors là, tu me poses une de ces colles. Écoute,
C'est une forme de réponse.
Non, non, non, non, non, non. Je réfléchis. Je réfléchis à ta question.
D'accord.
Je réfléchis à ta question et je réfléchis plutôt à la manière dont j'ai abordé la question avec mes filles. Parce que c'est plus ça.
Parce que moi, j'appartiens encore à une génération où effectivement, on n'en parlait pas trop, où c'était quand même un peu vécu comme une honte ou en tout cas, il fallait, quand on les avait, il fallait pas que ça se sache dans la maison.
C'est ça.
Il fallait le cacher. Bon. Et moi, j'ai élevé mes filles dans une tout autre approche, mais tout en leur signalant quand même que la perception de la société était telle qu'il fallait quand même qu'elles ne...
Qu'elles soient conscientes de la perspective de leur environnement, ouais.
Voilà, exactement. Exactement. Donc, en fait, on est quand même à une époque un peu charnière.
C'est ça, ouais.
Parce qu'on essaye de s'affranchir d'un certain nombre de diktats et d'emprisonnements tout en ayant conscience que la société n'y étant pas prête, il faut y aller quand même avec des gants de velours.
Oui. Et alors, une question sur, voilà, on évoquait cet idéal de la virilité qui est un construit. Est-ce qu'il existe un équivalent symétrique, un modèle que toutes les femmes cherchent à imiter ?
Voilà, un équivalent de la virilité pour les femmes, est-ce que ça existe ou absolument pas ?
Oui, bien sûr, c'est ce qu'on... alors ça, ça n'a pas de nom.
Oui.
Ça n'a pas de nom. Et pour cause, puisque toutes les essentialisations relatives au genre ont été, par la force des choses,
conceptualisées par les hommes, enfin formalisées par les hommes, puisque la femme n'avait pas voix au chapitre, elle a été reléguée dans le silence pendant des millénaires.
Donc toutes ces objectivations sont le fait des hommes. Et ce qu'on peut appeler l'éternel féminin, qui est le pendant de l'idéal viril, c'est effectivement une création des hommes.
Et cet éternel féminin, il est tout aussi coercitif et, comment dire, discriminatoire, en fait, pour les femmes.
C'est-à-dire qu'il faut être belle, féminine, avoir les cheveux longs, avoir la peau douce. Maintenant, il y a des canons aussi de poids,
de traits du visage, de régularité des traits et puis surtout des canons de comportement en société.
Il faut être douce, bienveillante, gentille. De toute façon, on l'est par nature dans cette définition.
On n'a même pas à se faire violence.
Nature entre guillemets, oui.
Voilà, d'une femme naturellement, entre guillemets naturellement bienveillante, gentille, empathique, douce, etc.
C'est l'évidence, finalement, oui.
C'est l'évidence et c'est ce qu'on peut appeler l'éternel féminin. Mais si je peux me permettre
d'être un petit peu mordante, il y a eu trois essentialisations du féminin par le masculin, c'est-à-dire que la femme avait trois possibilités : la vierge, la mère ou la pute.
D'accord, ok.
C'est-à-dire la vierge, c'est l'idéal absolu de sainteté, et c'est celle qui appartient à son père, historiquement.
La mère, c'est évidemment le devoir sacré de mettre des enfants au monde, donc qui est érigé comme
l'idéal absolu de la féminité, mais c'est celle qui appartient à son mari, hein, pendant des siècles, jusqu'à la deuxième moitié du vingtième siècle.
Et la pute, c'est celle qui appartient à tous, et qu'on a aussi théorisé comme un, entre guillemets, mal nécessaire.
C'est-à-dire, il fallait des prostituées, puisque évidemment, comme l'idéal féminin, c'était un idéal de virginité, y compris dans la maternité, figure de Marie, très paradoxale, qui nous invite à être mère tout en restant vierge.
Ça veut dire qu'en gros, la femme a été condamnée à ne pas jouir en réalité. C'est-à-dire, on voulait bien qu'elle, finalement,
on avait bien conscience qu'il fallait bien qu'elle y passe pour faire des enfants, mais alors surtout en n'en tirant aucun plaisir, puisque l'idéal, c'est la virginité.
Donc, il y a même certaines périodes de l'histoire où on a considéré que la frigidité était un gage de fertilité pour la femme.
Voilà. Et donc, il fallait bien des prostituées, pour satisfaire quand même l'appétit de luxure masculin.
Donc, on a considéré pendant toute l'histoire qu'elles étaient nécessaires pour que l'homme puisse exulter sans salir sa prude épouse.
Donc, une hypocrisie colossale parce qu'on avait besoin de la prostitution, mais on vomissait la prostituée.
C'est ça.
Ça, c'est une des hypocrisies majeures de ce système et une des injustices majeures faites à toutes ces pauvres femmes, dont on a toujours encouragé la vocation tout en les discriminant sur le plan social.
Mh. Oui. Alors, si tu as terminé sur cette trinité, mère, pute, vierge, j'aimerais faire un fast forward et arriver à notre époque contemporaine.
Il y a eu, bon, je le disais en début de podcast, les questions de genre sont un petit peu au cœur des questions de société, particulièrement ces dernières années.
Et un événement qui était très emblématique de ça, c'était, en tout cas, j'en ai le sentiment, l'élection présidentielle américaine, il y a deux ans, trois ans, trois ans déjà maintenant, qui opposait donc Hillary—
C'est bientôt fini.
Hillary Clinton et Donald Trump, et qui opposait donc une femme et un phallocrate. Et voilà, et je me souviens avoir écouté à l'époque, hein,
une émission de radio This American Life où on entendait, voilà, une femme en Utah qui voulait voter pour Hillary Clinton et tout son entourage lui disait : « Mais non, une femme à la Maison Blanche, tu n'imagines pas.
On va voter pour Donald Trump. » Et puis, il y a eu ce scandale parce que donc, voilà, le portrait de Donald Trump est riche en complexe viril.
Mais il y a eu cet épisode où, voilà, il y avait une caméra, une cassette qui avait été récupérée où il expliquait qu'il attrapait les top models par : « Grab them by the pussy », il avait dit.
By the pussy, oui.
Voilà, c'est ça. Et donc là, on entendait dans la bouche de ces électeurs qui vivaient en Utah, une once de doute.
Et puis : « Oh oui, non, mais on peut quand même pas voter pour une femme, hein. » Donc finalement, on va quand même voter pour Donald Trump.
Donc, il y avait, bon, il y a énormément de facteurs dans ces élections. On n'a toujours pas fini d'écrire à ce sujet-là.
On a fait un épisode à ce sujet avec Giuliano Da Empoli il y a quelques mois, où on expliquait l'importance des réseaux sociaux.
Oui, c'est un formidable épisode. Je le conseille à toutes celles et ceux qui nous écoutent.
Je vais l'écouter.
Et donc, de nombreux aspects, de nombreux facteurs dans cette élection. Mais le facteur de la virilité en politique m'intéresse beaucoup.
Alors, je tenais vraiment à te demander, Olivia, quel regard est-ce que tu portes sur l'actualité politique de ces dernières années ? En particulier donc la question de Donald Trump, mais on pourra parler d'Emmanuel Macron juste après.
Quel regard est-ce que tu portes sur l'actualité politique de ces dernières années ? Via ce prisme des questions de genre.
Je suis consternée.
Oui.
Je suis consternée. Je suis consternée, mais plus largement, au-delà de la question du genre hein, par la montée au pouvoir de gens qui se comportent comme des dictateurs.
Mais il n'y a pas que Trump, il y a Bolsonaro, Orban, Erdogan, voilà.
Le mouvement Cinq Étoiles, etc.
Salvini. Bon—
Oui, voilà. Tout à fait.
Pour le moment, il est un peu à l'écart, mais il va revenir. Et donc c'est... Si tu veux, moi, j'appartiens à une génération qui a cru vraiment à la chute du Mur.
Moi, j'ai vécu dans mon enfance, il y avait encore le communisme.
Et puis, on a vraiment cru. Je me souviens quand j'étais étudiante à Sciences Po, on était vraiment dans cette idée de fin de l'histoire, ça y est, l'humanité a compris, il faut aller vers plus de liberté publique.
Finalement, la démocratie parlementaire, c'est le meilleur régime possible, etc. On va vers le progressisme, les droits des femmes s'étendent.
J'ai vraiment cru qu'on était arrivé à ce stade, pendant toute ma jeunesse. Et puis là, force est de constater qu'on est en régression—
Mh.
Sur énormément, 'fin, sur cette question des libertés publiques, en tout cas—
Une forme de—
Ça me paraît évident.
Un retour de bâton, une forme de compensation ?
Ah oui, de backlash. Oui, oui. C'est Susan Faludi qui l'avait très bien vu. En fait, malheureusement, dans l'histoire, ça se vérifie hein,
que chaque fois qu'il y a une poussée émancipatrice, il y a un retour de bâton conservateur, rétrograde et ça s'opère par la violence.
Je ne sais pas du tout ce que vont donner les événements qui se passent, en tout cas au Chili, mais les images qu'on voit sur Twitter sont absolument effrayantes, de retour de militaires qui tirent dans le tas.
'Fin, je ne suis pas une spécialiste, encore une fois, donc je ne veux pas m'avancer. Je ne suis pas journaliste, je ne suis pas allée sur le terrain, mais je trouve ça très très choquant.
Et j'ai l'impression que sur beaucoup de points, on retourne vingt, trente, quarante ans en arrière.
Oui.
Il y a des gens qui sont nostalgiques de la dictature un peu partout, en Espagne, au Chili, en Argentine, au Portugal.
Les nostalgiques de la dictature. Et nostalgiques aussi, donc pour en revenir à notre question des genres—
Oui.
D'un ordre binaire qui, soi-disant, était beaucoup plus garant de la stabilité sociale. Ce qui n'est pas démontré du tout hein, mais bon.
C'est un sentiment qui revient souvent, effectivement.
Ouais. Et alors là, il faut faire démonstration. Les chefs d'État, bah, font la démonstration de l'étendue de leur pouvoir phallique.
On voit les poignées de main, la—
Oui, la poignée de main de Donald Trump—
Les concours de poignées de main. C'est un peu des... 'fin, là encore, je vais être triviale, mais c'est un peu des concours de bite, de taille de bite, c'est—
Mais d'ailleurs, dans les débats qui ont précédé l'élection de Donald Trump, il y avait, je crois, une histoire de : « J'ai des très grandes mains, vous savez ce que ça veut dire, etc. »
Exactement. Exactement.
Alors qu'en fait, il avait des petites mains.
Oui, en plus. En plus. Mais bon, comme si la taille de la main était l'indice du pouvoir sexuel. Et comme si la taille du sexe était l'indice aussi de la—
De la force, de la puissance.
De la qualité de la performance sexuelle. Enfin bon, de toute façon, tout ça, ce sont des...
Des âneries.
'Fin, il faudrait passer une journée complète à déconstruire chacun de ces discours tellement ils sont pleins d'âneries.
Mh.
Mais ce qui est quand même étonnant, c'est qu'il y a la moitié du peuple américain qui le suit et qu'il risque même de se faire réélire tout en disant des grosses âneries. Donc...
Alors bon, à l'heure où on enregistre cette émission, il y a surtout la question de l'impeachment. Je sais plus comment on dit en français, mais le—
Oui, impeachment, avec des procédures de destitution.
Voilà, destitution. Merci. Donc, oui, qui honnêtement pourrait tout à fait donner quelque chose. Donc voilà, on attendra de voir.
On espère, ouais.
Mais donc voilà, 'fin, grosso modo, le—
'Fin cela dit, Mike Pence est pire. Alors donc s'il était destitué—
C'est vrai.
On aurait son vice-président et je crois que là... Il faut attendre une prochaine élection présidentielle. Mais là où tu as raison tout à l'heure quand tu disais que la campagne, en fait,
la campagne contre Hillary Clinton était absolument révoltante de bassesse et de vulgarité.
Et il n'a pratiquement pas avancé un seul argument de programme de campagne où vraiment, mais c'était d'une pauvreté crasse.
L'essentiel de sa campagne électorale, il l'a faite en démontrant par A+B que Hillary Clinton était une sorcière ou à peu près.
Oui, qu'il fallait l'enfermer, etc.
Il fallait l'enfermer en prison.
Donc vraiment, on était en plein dans la chasse aux sorcières que lui a beau jeu de dénoncer maintenant à son tour, pour reprendre cette expression à son compte, en disant que la procédure d'impeachment, c'est de la chasse aux sorcières.
Il sait même pas de quoi il parle. Mais là aujourd'hui, on voit bien que les Alexandra Octavio Cortez et toutes les nouvelles figures féminines qui émergent
dans la politique américaine, elles souffrent, elles vont souffrir de ce discours-là—
Oui.
Qu'on ne va pas manquer de leur envoyer, qu'elles sont d'origine ethnique douteuse, de couleur de peau douteuse—
C'est ça.
Et du sexe inférieur. Donc ça fait quand même beaucoup de handicaps.
Mais donc, 'fin, là où je veux arriver, c'est cette notion de crise de masculinité qu'on a évoquée tout à l'heure.
Donc on a un petit peu le sentiment qu'il y a, voilà, tous ces hommes, en l'occurrence les hommes américains, surtout blancs, mais pas que,
qui ont conscience d'être privilégiés, mais quand même, si on pouvait arrêter de le répéter à longueur de journée, le politiquement correct, ça suffit au bout d'un moment.
Ils ont— Et voilà, et qui ont peur finalement que le mot masculinité
soit devenu synonyme de toxicité et que leur nature, bah voilà, on en revient à la question de ce qu'ils perçoivent comme étant leur nature, donc ce modèle de masculinité qui tend vers un idéal viril,
voilà, et qu'ils ont intégré dans leur identité, soit perçu comme quelque chose de fondamentalement toxique.
Et donc voilà, ce backlash qu'on évoquait il y a un instant— Qu'est-ce qu'on peut leur souhaiter à ces hommes ?
Est-ce qu'on peut leur souhaiter une émancipation ? Est-ce que c'est aux institutions d'enseignement de faire un travail à ce niveau-là ?
Qu'est-ce que t'en penses ?
Alors, moi, je crois beaucoup à l'éducation et je crois beaucoup à la génération à venir sur laquelle on a vraiment une prise en termes d'éducation.
Et y a de plus en plus d'enseignants... Moi, je reçois pas mal de courriers d'enseignants qui sont très sensibles à ça et qui me disent : « En fait, votre livre peut être utilisé comme outil pédagogique.
» Et ça, pour moi, c'est la récompense suprême—
Mais je vais aller tout à fait ça—
En tant qu'auteur et en tant que mère aussi. Donc, y a une chose que je voudrais quand même dire, c'est qu'il faudrait pas tomber dans l'illusion,
selon laquelle c'est la génération des plus âgés, des seniors, des plus de cinquante ans, blancs, hétéros, etc.,
qui sont d'affreux réacs qui veulent pas bouger pour conserver leur pouvoir et leurs prérogatives.
Et puis qu'on a des jeunes, au contraire, qui se bougent. C'est... En réalité, c'est pas du tout en termes d'âge.
Parce que moi, j'ai dans mes auditeurs des tas d'hommes qui, au contraire, ont cinquante et soixante ans et viennent me dire : « J'ai souffert toute ma vie de la normativité viriliste.
» Donc au contraire,
ils en sont,
ils y sont plus sensibles que n'importe qui d'autre parce qu'ils ont dû faire un service militaire obligatoire et qu'ils s'y sont pas reconnus, parce qu'ils ont souffert de discrimination pour telle ou telle raison ou tout simplement parce qu'
ils ne sont pas socialement puissants et prestigieux.
Donc, un chômeur aujourd'hui, quelqu'un qui est en situation précaire, qui n'arbore pas les signes extérieurs de la réussite avec la grosse voiture, la belle bimbo, etc.
Mais tous ces hommes-là, ils sont très sensibles à ces thèses-là. Et en revanche, on a des jeunes qui sont dans le virilisme le plus primaire, le plus agressif, le plus violent.
Donc ça n'est pas en termes d'âge, vraiment.
Notamment en France, je pense à des figures comme Alain Soral, Éric Zemmour.
Moi, c'est pour ça que je pense que la féminisation va provoquer des violences. Vous voyez, par réaction, parce que je pense qu'une virilité humiliée est une virilité qui se barbarise.
Alors qu'une virilité civilisée, encadrée, est utile à tout le monde, si j'ose dire.
Aux États-Unis, on peut peut-être penser à...
Mes copains. Mes copains.
Dans le monde anglophone, on peut peut-être penser à Jordan Peterson. Je sais pas si tu connais.
Oui. Bien sûr. I like the masculine spirit. It's necessary. And to put it symbolically is that your responsibility is to incarnate the spirit of the logos.
That's your responsibility. That's your role in life.
Et Joe Rogan aussi.
Oui.
Ladies, you do that. You make people, you make all the people. And you want to be president too, you fucking greedy bitches.
Jesus Christ. What else you want? You want bigger dicks than us? You want all the money? Ladies, I love you, but let's be honest, you don't invent a lot of shit.
Voilà, qui sont finalement des espèces de rôles modèles et qui inspirent, qui remuent cet idéal viril, non ? Je sais pas si tu es d'accord.
Alors oui, absolument. Mais c'est leur fond de commerce. Et je dis bien commerce parce que Jordan Peterson, il vend ses conférences extrêmement chères.
Il se déplace plus jamais gratuitement, même pour un interview. Il fait— C'est un fond de commerce, vraiment.
Et l'idée, c'est qu'en réalité, les femmes, par leur émancipation sexuelle et par le fait qu'elles ont bousculé ce binarisme et qu'elles ont pénétré les bastions masculins, elles sont jugées castratrices.
Et c'est comme si chaque conquête féminine, en fait, avait dépossédé les hommes de quelque chose. Ils ont perdu quelque chose.
Ils refusent absolument l'idée d'un monde qui soit partageable en deux, parce qu'il y a deux sexes et que chacun représente la moitié de l'humanité.
Donc, ils refusent complètement cette idée. Ils restent persuadés que l'homme a vocation à gouverner et que oui, on est bien sympa, on a fait une petite place à la femme, on l'a laissée travailler, etc.
Mais il faudrait quand même pas qu'elle en demande trop non plus parce qu'elle commence à nous les briser avec ses volontés d'émancipation.
Elles ont demandé le divorce, elles ont ruiné la famille,
elles sont majoritaires dans la justice, donc elles infestent la justice et donc les juges sont de parti pris dans les cas de divorce, etc.
Donc elles, en fait... L'émancipation des femmes est considérée comme ayant amené la ruine de la société. Donc c'est les...
Y a pas que l'immigration, si vous voulez, qui soit néfaste dans ce discours-là. Il y a aussi l'émancipation féminine.
Et c'est un peu, d'ailleurs, je dirais, un peu une seule et même chose, parce que c'est finalement rien d'autre qu'une idéologie de la domination.
Et c'est la domination de l'homme sur la femme, c'est la domination de l'homme sur le sous-homme, c'est la domination de l'homme sur l'animal.
Donc, on a le droit d'en faire ce qu'on veut et de le mettre dans des abattoirs ignobles. Et c'est la domination de l'homme sur la nature.
Et en ce moment, c'est tout le système qui est en train de montrer des signes de faiblesse. La planète commence à se révolter.
La cause animale aussi, elle a des représentants pour dire, des gens qui parlent au nom des animaux en disant : « Beh peut-être que ça suffit, ce système.
» Et les femmes. Donc, en fait, c'est tout un système qui est en train de se craqueler, de se déconstruire. Et évidemment, ça entraîne une réaction extrêmement violente de la part de ceux qui sont en position de domination.
Mais il n'y a que eux qui se sentent menacés. Il n'y a que les dominants qui aient tout à perdre de la remise en cause d'un système de domination.
Tous les dominés, eux, n'ont qu'à s'en réjouir.
Mh. Et est-ce que ton regard sur les amateurs de Jordan Peterson et de Alain Soral et compagnie, je fais des grosses approximations là, mais oui.
Ouais alors, d'abord, ils sont pas tous d'affreux masculinistes, hein. C'est-à-dire que
ce courant, on peut l'appeler masculiniste, c'est-à-dire le fait de
considérer qu'il y a une domination féminine, une tyrannie féminine, un fascisme féminin, qu'il y a une crise de la virilité, que c'est la fin des hommes, etc.
Ça, c'est un courant qu'on va nommer masculiniste, pour faire court, qui est aussi très misogyne. Cela dit, il y a aussi beaucoup d'hommes sincères, absolument pas misogynes,
pas du tout masculinistes, mais qui vivent actuellement une détresse qui est proprement masculine.
Et ça, il faudrait pas l'ignorer. C'est-à-dire que sans être pour autant d'affreux, enfin d'affreux masculinistes misogynes, il y a des hommes qui souffrent aujourd'hui.
Et c'est simplement ce que j'ai voulu montrer, c'est attirer l'attention du lecteur sur le fait qu'il y a, et de fait, et je ne le nie pas, une détresse qui est proprement masculine.
On peut en analyser les symptômes, hein. Il y a plus de burn out, il y a plus de suicides chez les hommes, il y a plus d'addictions, il y a plus de violence, il y a plus d'hommes en prison.
Maintenant, ils réussissent moins bien leurs études un peu partout dans les démocraties occidentales. Les femmes sont meilleures en classe, etc.
Donc il y a beaucoup de faits, de symptômes. Simplement, on se trompe en général de cause quand on en impute la responsabilité à l'émancipation féminine.
C'est-à-dire de dire les hommes vont mal, c'est la faute des femmes, c'est là l'erreur. Les hommes vont mal, oui, et ça, c'est une certitude.
Même dans les professions les plus viriles comme les policiers et les conducteurs de train, les pompiers même, il y a une détresse majeure au point qu'il y a énormément de suicides.
Donc ça ne peut pas ne pas poser question, tout ça. Moi, je pense qu'il y a une vraie détresse masculine. Sauf que la cause n'est pas l'émancipation féminine.
La cause, c'est le virilisme lui-même.
Et donc la clé, la solution, d'après toi, ce serait l'éducation. Il faut lire, il faut s'informer.
Alors, c'est une des clés, hein, mais il faudrait aussi peut-être changer complètement de système de représentation du monde dans sa globalité, c'est-à-dire cesser de considérer que
la nature même de l'homme, c'est de dominer.
Comme je l'ai dit, dominer la femme et dominer l'autre homme et dominer la planète et dominer dans le monde professionnel et dominer et conquérir.
Donc c'est peut-être cette idéologie-là qu'il faudrait pouvoir combattre à la racine en en montrant les effets délétères.
Simplement, les hommes n'ont donc peut-être pas forcément fait le lien entre la détresse qu'ils vivent et le système de représentation genré dont ils sont les victimes.
Mais je donne juste un exemple. Une femme qui se retrouve aujourd'hui au chômage, certes, elle est très handicapée, elle a moins d'argent, c'est un vrai problème.
Elle est dans une vraie détresse, mais elle ne se sent pas déféminisée. Elle ne se sent pas atteinte dans son identité de femme, dans son être.
Ce n'est pas quelque chose qui est ontologiquement blessant. Alors qu'un homme qui est au chômage,
puisque la virilité se définit par la conquête, l'action, l'argent, la puissance, le pouvoir, puisque l'homme est défini comme le seul pourvoyeur, pourvoyeur de ressources.
Un homme qui est au chômage ou un homme qui est tout simplement précarisé, lui, il a la double peine parce que non seulement il est dans la difficulté, mais en plus, il n'est plus regardé comme un homme, un vrai.
Et c'est pour ça qu'il se suicide. C'est pour ça qu'il se suicide, parce qu'il n'arrive plus à être de vrais hommes.
Donc c'est en ce sens que les canons de— on demande toujours aux hommes d'être performants, combatifs, conquérants, héroïques, de gagner des parts de marché, de gagner, de conquérir, de vaincre, d'abattre l'ennemi, etc.
On leur demande toujours autant, alors qu'en réalité, la société ne permet plus qu'à une poignée d'être dans cette situation et tous les autres sont écrasés.
Donc c'est tout à fait normal que la virilité traverse une crise majeure. Aujourd'hui, comment être encore un conquérant quand il n'y a pas de boulot ?
Comment être un conquérant quand on gagne mille cent euros ? Comment faire le pharaon devant les femmes et leur offrir des fleurs ?
C'est plus possible d'être aujourd'hui viril.
C'est possible en... Alors, je vais prendre des exemples extrêmes, mais ce serait peut-être une partie de l'explication des extrémismes.
Par exemple, le cas du djihadisme.
Mais totalement, absolument. C'est-à-dire qu'on préférera mourir en héros, hein, donc tout à coup,
se conquérir une identité héroïque par le djihadisme et la belle mort plutôt que d'avoir une vie jugée miteuse parce que socialement, on n'est rien.
Enfin, on n'est rien, je reprends la belle expression de Macron, d'Emmanuel Macron. Il y en a qui réussissent, il y en a qui ne sont rien.
Ah oui, mais ça en fait beaucoup des gens—
Ouais.
Qui ne... Non, mais quand je dis sont rien, c'est ironique hein.
Bien sûr, bien sûr.
J'ai été très choquée par cette phrase. Les gens qui ne sont rien. Mais justement, c'est avec ce genre de phrases qu'on fabrique de la détresse sociale, de la misère sociale et qu'on fabrique des hommes suicidaires.
Donc oui, il y a une détresse masculine, mais la cause a été très mal identifiée.
Mais donc voilà, on pointe ici une des causes, mais qui semble quand même une cause importante dans toutes ces problématiques, hein.
Voilà, j'ai donné l'exemple du djihadisme, on a donné l'exemple de l'élection de politiciens très, très, très à droite.
On a l'impression que ces problématiques-là ne seront pas résolues parce que donc voilà, on a jeté un œil au passé lointain, au Paléolithique, on jette un œil maintenant sur le présent, l'actualité récente.
Si on jette un œil sur le futur, j'aurais du mal à entendre que ces problématiques-là pourront être résolues d'ici une petite dizaine d'années et que on sera débarrassé de cette problématique.
Alors, résolu, sûrement pas, mais on fait quelques pas en avant. Par exemple, je pense que MeToo a quand même été un pas en avant.
Mh.
Même si je veux bien reconnaître avec certains hommes qu'il y a pu y avoir marginalement des dérives, des dénonciations, des impostures.
Oui, c'est possible. Ça m'intéresse pas beaucoup d'
aller plus loin. C'est possible. Mais ce qu'a apporté MeToo, c'est une mutation anthropologique majeure parce que c'était en finir avec deux millénaires de déni des violences faites aux femmes,
de culpabilisation systématique des victimes,
de déculpabilisation, au contraire, des coupables et de silence féminin.
Donc quand vous mettez ces quatre paramètres ensemble, ben, vous avez deux mille ans de violences sexuelles tues, subies dans la honte et constamment déniées.
Et donc là, j'ai l'impression quand même qu'on a fait un pas en avant parce que la libération de la parole féminine, maintenant quand même, on n'ose plus dénoncer les choses.
Les hommes, il y a beaucoup d'hommes aussi qui ont fait leur aggiornamento, hein. Moi, mon propre mari, il s'est remis en question.
Donc je pense qu'il y a quand même,
certains signes qui vont dans le sens d'une évolution positive, de fin de la guerre des sexes ou en tout cas de réflexion sur ces représentations genrées dans ce qu'elles ont de mortifère.
Et puis évidemment, comme à chaque fois qu'on fait un pas en avant, eh bien, certains voudraient nous ramener deux pas en arrière.
Donc, on a des réactions de virilisme forcené. Donc, tu as parlé des djihadistes qu'on peut interpréter comme du virilisme,
mais tu as aussi des gens qui se lâchent sur les réseaux sociaux en étant plus sexistes que jamais, plus misogynes que jamais, etc.
Là, encore une fois, c'est la peur. C'est la peur qu'a tout ce système qu'ils ont élaboré.
Là, mais tu vois, en fait, en même temps, cette peur, elle a un effet heuristique parce qu'elle nous montre que si les hommes ont peur que cette construction viriliste se défasse, ça signifie bien que c'est une construction.
Parce que si c'était si naturel que ça, ça ne pourrait pas être remis en question. On peut pas remettre en question le fait qu'il faut respirer pour vivre et manger.
C'est ça.
Et dormir.
Personne n'a peur que le ciel disparaisse, ouais.
Personne n'a peur que... Mais si on a peur que la virilité disparaisse, c'est précisément parce qu'elle est un idéal construit, artificiel, une fabrication.
Donc ce que l'histoire a fait, l'histoire peut aussi le défaire. Ça prouve bien à quel point ça n'est pas naturel. Donc, à chaque fois qu'on dit que la virilité est menacée, on signifie qu'elle n'est pas naturelle, en réalité.
Oui. Mais donc, je reviens à ma question de départ qui était : est-ce que
on peut être optimiste pour le futur proche ou bien est-ce que ces questions qui nous accompagnent depuis... voilà, tu donnais l'exemple de MeToo qui a été une révolution très importante,
mais qui n'a visiblement pas totalement suffi puisque les hommes restent prisonniers de cet idéal viril qui les emprisonne, qui les met dans un certain mal-être.
Est-ce qu'on peut être optimiste pour le futur à partir du moment où cet idéal viril est toujours là et nous accompagne depuis, voilà, des millénaires à présent ?
Tant qu'il y aura des guerres, on aura besoin de soldats et tant qu'on aura besoin de soldats, on aura besoin de ce mythe. Voilà.
Ok. Donc ça, c'est vraiment une fatalité pour le coup.
Mais c'est très lié à la guerre, quand même, cette histoire. C'est très lié au mythe. Le mythe guerrier, c'est quand même un mythe qui est central dans la construction du virilisme.
Alors, il s'est déconstruit aussi, lui aussi, petit à petit, 'fin, notamment à partir de la Première Guerre mondiale, qui a quand même, on change de mise en scène.
Ça, c'était très bien montré dans l'Histoire de la virilité de Vigarello, Corbin et Courtine.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils montraient que cette image du chevalier, puis du fantassin, puis du soldat qui s'avance fièrement sur le champ de bataille debout avec son uniforme rutilant, son casque, etc.
C'est une mise en scène qui est complètement révolue avec les tranchées, avec un homme qui pète de trouille, à plat ventre, dans les rats, dans les tranchées, dans la boue, qui a froid, qui a faim et qui a peur surtout.
Donc c'est vrai que cette image, elle a été très démonétisée. Cette image du guerrier invincible, elle a été très démonétisée par les conflits mondiaux,
puis toutes les guerres de décolonisation, puis toutes les atrocités des guerres en général.
Mais elle continue quand même, 'fin, la guerre continue à être quand même un moteur central des relations internationales, comme on le sait, parce qu'il y a des intérêts et des enjeux économiques évidents derrière.
Et donc, on est quand même, tant qu'on aura besoin de soldats, on aura besoin de leur dire qu'ils n'ont pas peur de la mort.
Et on aura besoin de leur dire que les hommes sont des héros.
Et à ce moment-là, est-ce qu'une solution, ça ne peut pas être, je m'en veux presque de dire ça, mais créer un idéal du soldat féminin et de dire : oui, les femmes aussi peuvent être violentes et meurtrières.
Est-ce que ça ne permettrait pas...
Alors, les femmes, le processus de féminisation dans l'armée, il s'est beaucoup accéléré dans les années soixante-dix à quatre-vingt, et...
Tu veux dire septante.
Ah pardon, pardon.
C'est une blague hein.
Dans les années septante à quatre-vingt. Et d'ailleurs depuis que l'armée se professionnalise, on manque un peu d'effectifs et donc on a sollicité même les femmes pour s'engager, en tout cas en France hein.
Mais il y a, même dans les sous-marins qui étaient souvent, 'fin, les derniers bastions avec l'aviation qu'on va confier aux femmes.
Là maintenant, l'armée française, il y a un taux de quinze pour cent de femmes, mais simplement, on dit qu'on les déploie pas souvent dans les opérations extérieures.
Elles représentent que quinze pour cent des officiers hein, et que six pour cent, puisque je viens vraiment de ressortir ma fiche...
Mh.
De femmes qui sont déployées sur des opérations extérieures. Mais ce que je veux dire par là, c'est qu'une armée
avec un esprit féminin, attention encore une fois, parce que là, ça voudrait dire qu'on en revient aux essentialisations, en disant : la femme va apporter la douceur et l'humanité à l'armée.
Mais non, c'est une armée plus humaine, tout simplement. Une armée plus humaine.
Mh.
C'est... par exemple, quand on dit, 'fin, une infirmière, je prends un autre exemple. Une infirmière qui va,
à la fin d'une journée de douze heures, trouver encore l'énergie de faire un sourire à un patient qui arrive aux urgences, a été mal ca-- C'est pas dans sa féminité qu'elle va chercher ça, c'est dans son humanité.
Et l'humanité, on l'a tous en partage. Donc moi, j'aurais tendance à dire non, c'est pas une armée plus féminine qu'il faut, c'est une armée plus humaine.
D'accord.
De la même manière que tout à l'heure, je disais un homme ne se féminise pas quand il repasse ses chemises. Une femme ne se masculinise pas quand elle a le goût du pouvoir ou quand elle fait du krav maga.
Non, elle se réapproprie simplement le fait d'être un humain complet.
Ouais.
Avec, pour certains individus, un appétit de pouvoir, pour d'autres complètement dépourvus.
Mais au-delà du genre, en fait, il faut cesser de considérer que le genre, c'est la première variable et que c'est la variable la plus importante pour qualifier et définir un individu.
C'est pas ça. L'individu, les individus sont multiples dans les deux genres.
Réhumaniser nos armées pour, voilà, se dépolariser un petit peu, enfin un petit peu, même beaucoup. Je dis beaucoup un petit peu, je me rends compte, mais...
Vous n'êtes pas prêt.
Se dépolariser à ce niveau-là. On va tout doucement devoir s'approcher vers la conclusion de cet épisode.
J'ai trois questions encore à te poser. La première concerne l'extrême droite en France, le Front national devenu Rassemblement national depuis quelque temps.
Ton président Emmanuel Macron, dont on a déjà évoqué quelques citations il y a un instant. Et enfin, voilà, une question de conclusion que j'aurais à te poser.
Donc, en ce qui concerne l'extrême droite française,
si on assimile, donc comme on l'a fait tout à l'heure, si on tisse un lien entre virilité et extrémisme politique, hein, on citait les Viktor Orbán, les Bolsonaro, les Donald Trump, etc.
Ce qui frappe avec le Rassemblement national, c'est qu'il a évidemment à sa tête une femme. Et il y a quelques années, il y avait même la figure de Florian Philippot, qui est donc homosexuel.
Ça fait un petit peu, je vais pas dire tache, mais c'est surprenant.
Oui, d'autant qu'il y a une deuxième femme, il y a Marion Maréchal hein, qui est toujours bien là et qui a certainement un avenir politique important, hélas. Et
là, alors,
j'allais dire que ça va aussi dans le sens de l'histoire. C'est-à-dire qu'ils sont bien obligés, de toute façon, d'accepter et d'être mis devant le fait accompli de l'évolution sociétale.
Et même, Florian Philippot est homosexuel, mais le Front national a aussi son musulman de service pour faire bien.
Donc de toute façon, ça ne fait que conforter l'idée, fausse à mon avis, qu'il représente la totalité de la société et qu'il la représente mieux que personne.
Mais plus profondément, on pourrait dire que le fait que justement, ce mouvement soit dirigé par deux femmes, enfin l'une après l'autre, vraisemblablement,
prouve bien que précisément, le goût du pouvoir n'est pas l'apanage du masculin et même le goût du pouvoir autoritaire n'est pas le goût du pouvoir.
Et que donc il y a des femmes qui sont,
entre guillemets, viriles selon les canons
définis plus haut, c'est-à-dire des femmes qui ne sont pas du tout définies par la gentillesse, la bienveillance, la douceur et la réclusion dans la sphère privée, mais qui, au contraire,
ont un appétit débordant de démontrer toute l'étendue de leur puissance.
Donc, ça va au contraire dans le sens de ma théorie, c'est-à-dire que tout ça est une construction. La preuve, c'est que même à l'extrême droite, ils ont une femme qui porte la culotte.
Donc, voilà. Mais je pense que c'est, si tu veux, le...
Elle a l'intelligence, Marine Le Pen, de ne pas tomber non plus dans certains des clichés sociétaux, justement parce que voulant se polariser sur la question de l'immigration,
elle a adouci par rapport au profil de son père.
Elle a voulu dédiaboliser le Front national. Donc ça passait par un discours qui en finissait avec l'antisémitisme et qui revenait sur la question du détail de l'histoire, etc.
Et les jeux de mots douteux de son père. Et aussi sur la question féministe, montrer un certain progressisme. Donc ça, c'est uniquement, à mon avis, c'est complètement politique.
Électoraliste même.
Électoraliste, oui, oui, oui. Mais elle ne peut pas aujourd'hui se prétendre moderne et vouloir gouverner si elle avait des idées complètement conservatrices sur le plan sociétal.
Donc là où elle appuie, là où elle pense que ça fait vraiment mal et là où elle peut rafler un maximum, c'est sur l'immigration.
Donc ça en revanche, le discours est resté très classique. Mais sur le reste, ils ont dû évoluer, par la force des choses, je dirais, sinon ils perdaient tous leurs électeurs.
Et donc la question alors à ce moment-là d'Emmanuel Macron, comment est-ce que tu juges la virilité, la masculinité de ton président Emmanuel Macron ?
Bon, alors, je vais te répondre d'autant plus à l'aise que ce podcast sera écouté essentiellement en Belgique, si j'ai bien compris. Pas trop en France.
La majorité des auditeurs sont belges, effectivement, des auditeurs et auditrices.
Mais voilà un phénomène qui est très très intéressant sur le plan de la virilité parce que Emmanuel Macron partait avec une sorte de déficit viril, une sorte de handicap même de virilité.
Je ne sais même pas si c'était assumé et conscient de sa part, mais il y avait d'abord ces rumeurs d'homosexualité persistantes pendant toute sa campagne.
Il y avait le fait qu'il n'a pas d'enfant. Or, la paternité, c'est un marqueur viril...
Essentiel, oui.
Essentiel. Et troisièmement, le fait qu'il soit marié à une femme plus âgée dans la misogynie ambiante, c'était, je vais parler crûment, elle est pas baisable, donc il est pédé.
Ce qui est d'ailleurs une attaque que Bolsonaro a fait récemment.
Ah non, mais c'était ignoble.
C'était puéril, ouais.
C'était ignoble, ignoble, ignoble. Et donc, il partait avec ces trois handicaps : la femme plus âgée, donc vraisemblablement avec laquelle on ne peut pas avoir d'échanges sexuels,
la rumeur d'homosexualité et le fait qu'il n'était pas père.
Et puis certainement peut-être d'autres complexes, j'en sais rien. Mais en tout cas, ces trois événements, ces trois facteurs...
Ouais, il y avait un déficit de virilité en termes de perspective, oui.
Voilà. Pendant la campagne. Et qu'est-ce qu'il a fait ? Dès qu'il a été élu, il a eu cette obsession de la verticalité. D'abord dans la mise en scène du Louvre, la pyramide, c'est bien triangulaire.
Parce que le triangle aussi, c'est un symbole. D'abord, c'est un symbole très viril. Le triangle, c'est la Trinité, hein, le Père, le Fils, le Saint-Esprit.
Et puis c'est le triangle très bien décrit par Rubens, le triangle parfaitement isocèle de la carrure masculine, par opposition aux ovales mollassons de la féminité.
Donc, le triangle, enfin la pyramide du Louvre, cette mise en scène. Et puis après, il a remonté les Champs-Élysées sur un char.
Sur un char. Donc ça y est, je suis le chef des armées. Moi, je vous montre, je suis un combattant. Et après, il y a eu toutes sortes de démonstrations de virilité.
La poignée de main à Trump, hein, on ne savait pas qui allait lâcher le premier. Et puis cette façon aussi paternaliste de toucher les gens,
comme autrefois le roi, les écrouelles, hein : Je vais vous guérir rien qu'en vous touchant.
Donc on sentait qu'il y avait chez lui un désir de, encore une fois, de verticalité et de
domination presque monarchique, de nostalgie, de cette transcendance verticale du souverain et du roi qu'il a voulu réactiver.
Ça lui a pas du tout réussi d'ailleurs, mais il a été longtemps persuadé que la France désirait cette verticalité-là, que la France était profondément monarchiste.
Et tu penses que ce sont...
La France,
c'est Alain Duhamel qui l'avait très bien montré dans un petit livre il y a quelques années, qui s'appelle Le Complexe d'Astérix, où il montrait que le Français était un être éminemment paradoxal,
notamment parce qu'il était à la fois monarchiste et régicide.
Ouais, ouais, ouais, tout à fait, ouais.
Et c'est vrai que tu...
J'ai lu cet été la biographie de Marie-Antoinette par Stefan Zweig et en fait, j'ai été très étonnée par le nombre de vive le roi, vive le roi qu'il y avait partout sur son passage, même encore trois, quatre ans avant la guillotine.
Et ils ont été les premiers à s'empresser de lui couper la tête. Et d'ailleurs, en coupant la tête du roi, couper la tête aussi de la paternité.
Parce que le régicide, c'est aussi une forme de parricide.
Mais la comparaison qui se prête bien à ça, c'est la présidence de François Hollande où les gens dansaient et chantaient dans la rue le jour de son élection.
Et puis, voilà, il a fini avec quatre pour cent de popularité. Il a fini détesté avec, je crois, quatre pour cent dans les sondages.
C'est... voilà, c'est un truc assez récurrent effectivement en France, cette idée d'adorer un nouveau monarque, et puis de le détester rapidement après.
Voilà. Voilà, exactement.
Mais justement, je pense que quand tu parles de cette stratégie d'Emmanuel Macron, de vouloir
bien établir cette verticalité et tout ça, je pense qu'il avait appris ou enfin, en tout cas, il avait tiré les conclusions vis-à-vis de la présidence de François Hollande.
Et voilà, il y avait toutes ces images de François Hollande sous la pluie avec, oui, voilà, Flamby sous la pluie avec ses...
Le Flamby mollasson.
Voilà.
Exactement.
Ben je crois qu'il avait très peur de ça.
Oui, oui, oui, oui, totalement, totalement. Cela dit,
la virilité de François Hollande avait été aussi bien installée par la manière dont il s'est un peu débarrassé de sa concubine quand elle est devenue gênante.
Voilà, donc c'était pas non plus quelqu'un qui manquait totalement de virilité au sens où je l'ai défini.
Mais il était perçu effectivement, à tort je pense, hein, mais perçu comme quelqu'un de mollasson, de grassouillet.
Mais ça, c'est le côté... Mais c'est Sarkozy qui avait dit : Il mange des frites. Il mange des frites. Donc ça veut tout dire.
Ça veut dire il sait pas se contrôler. Ce n'est pas un vrai homme. Il mange du gras.
Il y a un côté très belge chez François Hollande. Mais ça, c'est une autre question.
Ils sont tellement sympas les Belges.
Mais donc on arrive tout doucement à la conclusion de ce podcast. La question que je voulais te poser pour clore...
Oui.
...pour les hommes qui nous écoutent, qu'est-ce qu'on peut leur souhaiter vis-à-vis de, voilà, ces questions de genre et tout ce qu'on a pu développer aujourd'hui ?
Quel conseil est-ce que tu leur donnerais ?
En fait, moi je pense que ce que je souhaite aux hommes, c'est une réinvention des masculinités, on l'a compris hein, hors de ces schémas qui sont assez mortifères.
Et concrètement, ça passe aussi, et c'est en ce sens que cette réinvention des masculinités est pour moi le seul avenir possible du féminisme.
Parce que la réflexion sur l'essence du féminin, ça y est, elle est menée. On a compris que la femme n'était pas simplement un ventre pour faire des enfants et douce et gentille, etc.
Ça, on l'a compris. Maintenant, concrètement, ce qui fait encore blocage et qui justifie le plafond de verre et les discriminations,
c'est encore cette idée que c'est à l'homme qu'incombe toute la conquête de l'espace, le travail, l'extériorité, etc.
Et ça justifie que
dans la sphère professionnelle, on continue à considérer que la femme vaut un petit peu moins qu'un homme et dans certains cas, beaucoup moins qu'un homme, notamment dans les métiers technologiques ou techniques où
elles n'osent même pas aller tellement elles ne sont pas considérées comme légitimes, en réalité.
Et donc, je pense que tout ça, déjà, ça commence dans le foyer. C'est les féministes des années 70 qui disaient : « Le privé est politique ».
C'est-à-dire que qu'est-ce qui justifie qu'une femme est payée en moyenne 15 à 20 % de moins qu'un homme à formation égale et à titre égal ?
C'est qu'à un moment, elle va s'arrêter pour faire des enfants, pour élever ses enfants, elle va partir à 5 heures de l'après-midi pour aller à la crèche, etc.
Ben justement, tant que les hommes ne prendront pas, 'fin, y aura pas un vrai partage de la charge parentale, tant qu'il n'y aura pas un congé paternité qui soit presque l'équivalent du congé maternité,
tant que, en fait, dans la sphère privée, on n'aura pas changé ces logiques de domination et ces logiques virilistes, eh bien,
on continuera à exclure les femmes de la sphère du pouvoir. C'est tout simple.
Mais ce sera aussi une libération pour les hommes, comme je le disais tout à l'heure. Un homme qui
se considère vraiment l'égal de son épouse en droit, ça signifie évidemment pas qu'il veut avoir des règles et qu'elle, elle veut avoir un phallus.
Ça, c'est vraiment la déformation stéréotypée—
Ouais, ouais, ouais.
...par laquelle on veut dévaloriser les études de genre. C'est horripilant.
C'est : « Ah, vous êtes pour l'indifférenciation des sexes, alors on peut plus offrir des poupées aux petites filles, on va les faire jouer aux camions et on va...
» Bon, tout ça, c'est vraiment pour décrédibiliser la thèse et ça n'a aucun intérêt. C'est pas ça que les femmes demandent du tout.
Les femmes demandent à avoir les mêmes droits, à avoir le même salaire et à avoir les mêmes possibilités en termes d'évolution de carrière.
Et elles demandent à ne plus être violentées et violées et harcelées sexuellement. C'est tout simple, celle-ci.
Elles demandent pas à devenir des hommes. Donc les hommes aussi vont y trouver un intérêt parce qu'avoir une épouse qui est cultivée, qui...
Eh bien, elle sera beaucoup plus intéressante comme mère pour ses enfants que si elle ne l'est pas. Une épouse qui va travailler et qui va gagner bien sa vie, eh bien, c'est une émancipation aussi pour son mari.
Parce que du coup, ça laisse à son mari ou à son conjoint,
la possibilité d'avoir tout à coup une année de redéfinition professionnelle ou une année de chômage ou tout à coup une année sabbatique, tout simplement parce que quelqu'un peut prendre le relais.
Donc c'est aussi un allègement du fardeau qui consiste à être le seul pourvoyeur de ressources.
De la même manière, quand les hommes se sont— 'fin, les antiféministes,
de la vieille garde qui disent que les femmes ont voulu l'émancipation sexuelle et que ça n'a amené que la catastrophe dans la famille, etc.
J'ai envie de leur dire : « Mais vous en avez pas aussi profité, vous, de la pilule et de l'IVG ? Ça vous a pas arrangé aussi que les femmes n'aient pas peur d'avoir des enfants à chaque fois qu'elles se couchaient dans votre lit ?
» Donc faut arrêter de considérer que l'émancipation féminine lèse les hommes. L'émancipation féminine doit être comprise comme une émancipation du genre humain dans son ensemble.
Moi, je pense que le féminisme est un humanisme, que l'antisexisme est une émancipation pour les deux sexes, que les deux genres ont été construits en se faisant face et dans une optique hiérarchisée de domination.
Et les deux sexes ont à gagner d'une vraie égalité et d'un vrai partage du monde.
Mais c'est une magnifique conclusion, Olivia. Je te remercie d'avoir passé un peu plus que Septante Minutes Avec Moi.
Mais c'était un vrai plaisir. Écoute, à moi, à mon tour de te faire un remerciement et un compliment parce que j'ai trouvé tes questions particulièrement pertinentes,
à tel point que j'ai dit des choses, j'ai pas dit des choses que j'ai l'habitude de dire.
J'en ai dit d'autres—
Oh.
...parce que— oui, et—
Je fais très bien semblant de savoir ce que je fais.
Ouais. Eh ben écoute, bravo, tu joues très bien la comédie parce que tes questions étaient... D'abord prouvaient que tu m'avais lue et comprise.
Et ça n'est pas toujours le cas de ceux qui m'interviewent. Je tiens à le dire et ça se sent. Et deuxièmement, tes questions montraient un réel enthousiasme pour ce sujet.
Voilà, et ça se sent. Et du coup, je pense qu'il n'y a pas de bon podcast, y a pas un bon podcasteur et y a pas de bonne interview s'il y a pas un bon intervieweur.
Donc, Guillaume, malgré ton jeune âge, je te trouve déjà très pro.
Ah oui, donc un petit peu de jeunisme malgré tout.
Ouais, je te trouve très pro. Non, mais parce que j'ai vu ton âge sur— je sais pas où j'ai vu ton âge, mais je sais que t'as même pas 30 ans.
Je n'ai même pas 30 ans.
T'es un petit garçon.
Olivia, donc merci beaucoup pour ce compliment, c'est très gentil.
Non, non, c'est sincère.
Et donc, dans ce cas-là, on est tous les deux gagnants.
Eh ben, si je peux aller encore plus loin.
Mais oui, je t'en prie.
Dans le compliment, ça n'enlève rien au caractère individuel du compliment que je viens de te faire. Mais quand je suis allée en Belgique, j'ai aussi trouvé que la qualité des interviews était nette— enfin, je dirais pas—
Mh.
Supérieure, mais qu'elle était excellente. J'étais revenue emballée de ma journée de promotion en Belgique. Donc—
C'est pour ça que tu as accepté cette interview. Du coup, tu t'es dit : Bon, il est Belge, ça va, ça va le faire.
J'avais un très beau— j'avais une très bonne, euh... Je partais avec un très bon... Comment on appelle ça ?
A priori.
Voilà, je partais avec un très bon a priori. Oui oui. Voilà.
Olivia, merci beaucoup.
Oui, non, merci à toi.
Comme je le disais, c'était un plaisir partagé.
Plaisir totalement partagé. J'espère que ça le sera par les auditeurs.
J'espère aussi. Et, chers auditeurs, du coup, on se retrouve dans deux semaines. Au revoir.
Au revoir.
Et voilà, une heure quarante, record battu. Je crois que c'est l'épisode le plus long de l'histoire de ce podcast. J'espère que c'était aussi agréable pour vous que ça l'a été pour nous.
On a passé un très bon moment et honnêtement, il y a encore tellement de sujets qu'on aurait pu aborder ensemble. Par exemple, à l'avenir, moi, j'aimerais bien approfondir encore un peu plus la question de la masculinité en politique.
On a aussi évoqué la question de la religion et son rôle dans l'oppression des femmes, mais par contre, on n'a pas du tout parlé du voile islamique.
Un sujet qui m'intimide très fort et que j'ai très peur de traiter maladroitement. Tant de questions qu'il reste à aborder et qui sait, peut-être qu'Olivia reviendra dans ce podcast pour le faire avec moi.
Si cet épisode vous a plu, je me permets de vous suggérer trois petites idées. Tout d'abord, si ce n'est pas déjà fait, abonnez-vous au podcast sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée
et allez suivre Septante Minutes Avec sur Facebook et Twitter, comme ça, vous êtes sûr de ne rien louper.
J'ai mis les liens dans la description. Deuxièmement, n'hésitez pas à m'écrire sur ces plateformes. Ce podcast est absolument gratuit.
Je fais ça avant tout par passion et donc mine de rien, quand je reçois un message encourageant, un retour critique ou autre, autant vous dire que ça fait vraiment plaisir.
Et enfin, troisièmement, quand un épisode vous plaît, n'hésitez pas à en parler à vos amis. Je publie toujours un extrait de deux petites minutes sur Facebook et Twitter.
C'est très facile à partager et ça donne un aperçu rapide du podcast.
Voilà, c'est tout pour moi.
Sauf imprévu, dans deux semaines, je recevrai Maître Christophe Marchand, qui est l'avocat d'un paquet de personnalités controversées comme Julian Assange, l'indépendantiste catalan Carles Puigdemont ou autrefois Edward Snowden.
À très vite sur les réseaux. Ciao.